since leaping into the world of
serverless critter junction's been
reaching new limits
but i've got a few tricks to take it up
to the next level
stay tuned
a core promise of serverless compute
platforms like cloud run and cloud
functions is that you don't need to
worry about your infrastructure
your service skills automatically
that works great when your whole stack
auto scales but what if your service
depends on api
or databases with rate or connection
limits
that's what happened with critter
junction's new companion app codenamed
the wallet app
it allows users to send or receive
virtual currency
over a marketplace every time a user
sends or receives cash
the change the user wall data in the
database kicks off a cloud function
to return a confirmation cloud function
is a
lightweight serverless compute solution
that lets you
create single purpose and standalone
functions that respond to cloud events
and because serverless compute products
are stateless
they use cloud sql a fully managed
relational database service for stateful
data like user wallet amounts
after the wallet app gained popularity
because of youtube live streamers
cloud sql's maximum connection limit was
reached
and that meant the upstream functions
weren't able to provide
new wall amount confirmations
so my team came in to give them a few
tips to scale the wallet app
and any future serverless workloads they
plan to deploy
let's review how serverless functions
scale as you take a function from your
local computer to the cloud a function
takes
inputs and provides an output response
that function can be repeated with many
inputs and provide
many outputs a serverless platform
manages the elastic horizontal scaling
of function
instances because google cloud can give
you near infinite scale
that can have consequences for other
systems that your function interacts
with
so what do you do well a lot of what i'm
about to tell you
involves applying limits to operations
to protect
underlying services and resources first
off you can configure
instant scaling limits to your functions
cloud functions offer max
instant settings this feature limits how
many concurrent instances
of your functions are running and
attempting to establish database
connections
so if your database can only handle 100
concurrent connections
you might set your max instances to a
lower value
say 75 since each instance of a function
can only handle
a single request at a time this means
you can only handle 75 concurrent
requests
at a given time saving your database for
maxing out
at its rate limit even during a spike
second use cloud tasks to limit the rate
of work done
sometimes the limit you're worried about
isn't the number of concurrent
connections but the rate at which
work is performed for example
imagine you need a call to an external
api that has a limited
per minute quota cloudtask is a fully
managed service that lets you manage the
execution
dispatch and delivery of distributed
tasks
you can manage the way work gets done
and perform the work outside of the
serverless handlers
in work queues cloudtask supports
rate and concurrency limits so
regardless of its rate at which work
arrives it's performed with rates
applied
for example if large influx of api
requests come in
cloud tasks can buffer the rate at which
your request can be handled by the api
third use stateful storage to defer the
results from long running operations
sometimes you want your functions to be
able to defer work that might take a
while
but still give a response to the caller
that the task was received you want to
send the results of the task to the
caller
eventually also known as long-running
operations
for example it might not make sense to
encode a large video file
inside a serverless instance you could
use cloud tasks
if the caller of your workload only
needs to know that the request was
submitted
but if you want the caller to be able to
retrieve a status or eventual result
you need an additional stateful system
to track that job there are several ways
you can do this using a combination of
cloud functions
cloud pub sub and firestore while
critter junction has just started to
explore serverless with cloud native
apps like the layout and wallet apps
they're constantly revisiting how to
improve performance and scalability
like using mac serverless instances
cloud tasks to limit the rate of work
and stateful storage for long running
operations
for more details on these tips and an
awesome decision tree check out the link
below
and stay tuned for our next serverless
scaling tips and remember
always be architecting
[Music]
you